a special guest has to be this card it's
the concept that everybody was waiting
for at the Los Angeles car show we saw
it unveiled last night in an incredible
mansion in the Hollywood Hills
overlooking the city and it's really
stunning I mean for a moment this was
more important than the view which was
amazing tell us about this because it
really represents the future of Audis
design language so we're gonna see it in
the next 8 the next 8 7 the next a 6
that's exactly right
I mean this is the future of Audi and I
think a couple of things you're going to
see in this car is obviously you see a
very bold front end very bold grill you
see a lot of high-tech features which is
very much Audi the 3-dimensional LED
lights in the rear and I think a couple
of cool things of course ow d stands for
Quattro and we want to make you know
these technologies really stand out in
the design so you'll really see the bold
force of Quattro on the front on the
front wheel as where is the real wheel
so in it's very high-tech check this out
just push just put your finger there and
the door opens for you which is quite
cool I hope we see that carried through
to the production but go ahead and get
in and show us the interior because it's
some it's a very different kind of
interior than you'd expect to see and I
know your party started doing this in
the TT and some of the other products
exactly right I mean what you have here
of course is our famous virtual cockpit
but we you'll notice here in this
virtual cockpit is it's
three-dimensional and you can see how
deep into the screen and you can see
this does not exist anywhere I think the
other thing you'll see is obviously this
is an LED screen but it's a flexible LED
screen so if you see from the design the
LED screen actually bends into the
contours and we find you don't see this
anywhere another slick feature is
basically as opposed to having wood or
aluminum here we turn this entire panel
into the screen the passenger is able to
get involved with music and navigation
and direct
and I know the crazy flick feature if
passenger navigates you can swipe send
it from here into the car and then of
course the driver then navigates to so
it's very Minority Report really one on
over some cool and I think it really
speaks to this concept of what Audi is
outtie is high tech and high design and
that's really a blend of that right
there so we love it we love it
let me ask you today Elon Musk tweeted
the noises that you see all these
awesome concept cars but you can't go
out and buy one I've seen a lot of
really awesome concepts out of you guys
look you had the sport Quattro and I
know this isn't necessarily get some for
production but is it gonna carry through
soon or gonna see these features
look if out he is known for one thing
and I appreciate mr. most tweets of
course out there but look the brutal
truth is this concept that led to the to
seven concepts that led to the magical
are a new ilaria which of course led to
the a five we're not in the business of
making a car and this refined this
production ready just for pipe dreams
and space talk we make things real
that's what he does let me also ask you
it seems like the theme this show has
been safety and sustainability the kind
of technology for some viewers technique
is what you say in Germany it seems like
it used to be at odds by having a green
car with the performance but now those
two things have moved together that's
exactly right and I think look if you
make green purely a rational woe-is-me
type of thing for a luxury brand it's
never going to work you got to make
being green and being environmental and
economical a really smart cool sexy
choice I think it's what you see here I
think that's what you see in a vehicle
like the H Tron I think it's what you
see on our plugins and it's certainly
it's what you'll see in our beds if you
never want someone entering into a 65
$60,000 decision going for the least
common denominator for us it's about
getting the greatest common that are
there absolutely absolutely they married
you're looking at I mean II Tron is your
electric hybrids age truck I'm guessing
as a hydrogen
exactly right so you're you haven't
picked one yet you're still look I think
the market is still open and fluid and I
think there's a lot of emerging
technologies obviously with the
combustion engine it's quite set and
it's been that way for a hundred years
with these technologies there's still a
lot of breathing room and the good news
about us we're well capitalized we have
the finances we can invest in this
technology and let the market take it
but certainly electric is here to stay
whether it's blog or whether it's full
bath no debate